what do you think that there's another
buyer that could emerge though for Time
Warner and investors loved Time Warner
investors love this idea sure well who
else is large enough to do this you can
look at Disney you could look at comcast
it becomes challenging beyond that there
aren't a lot of people who can swallow a
company that size and then you're going
to run into issues of hey is this going
to be anti-competitive how much of an
overlap is that between Disney and time
warner or perhaps comcast it raises
questions I'm fascinated by the game
theory that goes on with Rupert Murdoch
who has always been a crafty deal maker
if you look back of the history of him
over the past 50 60 years about 19 major
deals and a whole bunch of minor deals
he's very much grown by acquisitions I
don't know if this was too big to make
happen or maybe that sort of mega deal
is this is not the right environment is
you know he said management wouldn't
respond I wouldn't engage in toxin they
weren't interested I mean you know and
dick Parsons just saying it to me seven
days ago that he knew management new
members of the born he said with no
inside knowledge I really question
whether or not this deal could well well
you look at the terms that were
originally proposed and it's not like
they were off by a couple of dollars but
this was not exactly a great set of
rules for time-water shareholders